dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly show knife ahead this
piece of work shows us how to render a
piece of cloth down to the level of
fibers this is a difficult problem
because we need to be able to handle
models that are built from potentially
over a hundred million fiber curves this
technique supports a variety of goodies
one level of detail is possible this
means that the closer we get to the
cloth the more details appeared and that
it is possible to create a highly
optimized algorithm that doesn't render
these details when they are not visible
this means a huge performance boost if
we are zoomed out to optimizations are
introduced so that fiber level staff
shadows are computed in real time which
would normally be an extremely long
process note that we are talking
millions of fibers here and three the
graphical card in your computer is
amazingly effective at computing
hundreds of things in parallel however
its weak point is data transfer at which
it is woefully slow to the point that it
is often worth we computing multiple
gigabytes of data right on it
just to avoid uploading it to its memory
again this algorithm generates the fiber
clips directly on the graphical card to
minimize such data transfers and hence
it Maps really effectively to the
graphical card and the result is a
remarkable technique that can render a
piece of cloth down to the tiniest
details with multiple different kinds of
yarn models and in real time what I
really like about this piece of work is
that this is not a stepping stone this
could be used in many state-of-the-art
systems as is right now the authors also
made the plus models available for
easier comparisons in follow-up research
works thanks for watching and for your
generous support
now see you next time
[Music]